[Musique]
delage delaunay belleville d'armance en
ford par levasseur renault bugatti
amilcar tels sont les noms fabuleux des
voitures qui ont tourné aux trois heures
de contres dans le loir et cher cette
compétition n'a guère d'équivalent
il s'agit d'une course de résistance
pour des voitures vieilles de 73 à 44
ans cette confrontation internationale
regrouper des tacots venant de suisse
allemagne belgique hollande des grande
bretagne le départ a été donné ce style
des anciennes 24 heures du mans et ce
fut ensuite sur une piste détrempée une
lutte acharnée
bien entendu n'était plus question
vitesse qui d'ailleurs était limité à 25
km heure de classement il y en eut un
bien sûr mais dans cette compétition
l'essentiel était de participer de la
foire levassor de 1898 elle amilcar de
1926 il n'y avait qu'un pas faire et
ainsi on a pu voir les progrès de
l'automobile du début du siècle
c'est ainsi que sur le circuit de
conques on a fait un retour en arrière
en sentant l'huile de ricin et en voyant
ces bolides insolite
[Musique]